Jr has had difficulty moving since
suffering a stroke last December he
can't walk up the stairs in his home so
when flood waters rose on Sunday he and
his family had to evacuate
they said it was a super typhoon we
thought we'd get flooded for sure so we
left for safer grounds true enough the
flood came
super typhoon noru dumped torrential
rains as it crossed the Philippines
largest island Luzon
fortunately for people in Manila the
downpour stopped just as Rivers began to
overflow
by Monday morning those who fled to
safety were back cleaning up their homes
while government workers cleared their
streets
there were fears the Philippine Capital
would suffer catastrophic flooding
reminiscent of that of typhoon kitsana
back in 2009 but it was largely spared
the local environment officer of this
Manila suburb says the dredging of
waterways also made a difference
we were dredging every day so that gave
the river the capacity to hold more rain
president Ferdinand Marcus Jr also
praised the preparedness of the
government and of the people
I think uh though it's clear
from this uh
from what we did this last two days is
that very very important is preparation
get people out of the areas of danger
put all of your assets that you're going
to use
despite those preparations noru was
destructive several rescue workers
became the first known victims of the
storm an entire villages in the
countryside remain flooded
many fear the full extent of the damage
is only just starting to become clear
Al Jazeera Manila